foreign
and we know how we do
ladies and gentlemen
daddy is back in the building
so welcome back to your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everybody back in the
building
had to miss last week and I'll tell you
all about wine Daddy's busy
um what else is going on the wga
the strike is over hopefully sag will be
next
[Music]
debacle right now I'm gonna talk about
that
and I directed I'm directing
um a lot of stuff going on but as usual
you know where you at
[Music]
foreign
yeah love that
have you guys noticed that Instagram is
taking forever to like upload your
stories doesn't it feel like it's taking
forever but anyways welcome back to
River with Griffin everybody I
appreciate you guys being here uh for
all you loyal fans I know you're like
thanks where were you last week you know
so like the the 10 of you that are that
are real loyal like that you guys are
like where the hell were you Griffin I
was waiting for you you know it is what
it is you know life gets in the way
sometimes so
you know
that's how we you know it just it just
happens like that you know what I mean
but anyways welcome back to Riverwood
Griffin you know how we do here
um
comedy podcasts sometimes serious
sometimes introspective sometimes silly
but always 100 authentic Eric Griffin so
thanks for being here I appreciate you
guys
um let's see so we got so make sure you
hit the Subscribe button you know I'm
always on Twitch so follow me on Eric
Griffin gaming I'm really trying to like
build that up you know it's been a tough
I haven't been able to game as much as I
would like in the last few weeks and
stuff right so you gotta hit me up there
or you could be uh you know if you want
to financially support the show you
could do it many ways
patreon YouTube member uh twitch
subscriber
all those kinds of things help me keep
the show going and I appreciate you guys
as always
for being here
um today's sponsor of the show
oh you know what I have this written
wrong on here I actually have to change
this but I'll show you this now but
today's sponsor of the show is doordash
doordash
um
make sure you get 50 off okay wait let
me turn that off you get 50 off your
first doordash order up to 25 value when
you use code
rwg grocery at checkout that's rwg
grocery at checkout limited time offer
and terms apply thank you doordash for
sponsoring the show
yeah you know how we do guys
um so what's the word I hope everybody's
well hope everybody had a good week uh
you know I had quite a week myself
um you know just so much going on you
know what I mean I I was um I'm still
acting in this movie which actually
today is my last day I just had a really
late
what do you call it had a really late
um call time today so that's why I was
like oh I got to get my podcast in
because I didn't I didn't get to do it
last week for for just that reason you
know it's just like
it just
I just couldn't do it you know I was
like get I was getting
I was just like coming home so late it
was like 12 hour days that we're having
right now so I was like oh man there's
no way to do this how can I you know
what I mean I was like how can I you
know and it's just like you just make a
choice I mean I like being consistent
with the podcast
um and I'm sorry guys I'm doing
something at the same time because I
forgot to like do this thing I know you
probably probably people probably
listening being like what's wrong with
him but you know it is what it is
okay so just bear with me people
um yeah so and the movie's going great
um shout out once again to the director
writers uh Charisse Dorff you know doing
good uh you know one of the stars of the
movie is uh Lisa Edelstein if you guys
are if you guys are a house fans you
know so she was uh
the boss and house you know she was
great she's great you know she really is
a fantastic like
professional actor you know like just
being like just the things that she's
aware of you know she's like oh I'm
aware of stuff
like you know you know what I mean like
it's like she'll be like oh this is the
emotions for this and that and she can
make adjustments and you know she cries
when she needs to cry it's just like
such a pleasure watching somebody be
such a professional actor you know
so that's good
um
let's see what else is going on
I don't know I have so much to talk
about today and thanks for being in the
chat you know all you guys that are in
chat appreciate you guys okay so thanks
for being here you guys are
always welcome
and if you're listening uh on Apple
music or
all the different places you can get
your podcast I appreciate you guys for
uh you know being there so that's that's
a pleasure too to have uh people you
know it makes you leave your comments
and all that kind of stuff so that's I
want to get to but something that's
going on with my computer right now I
cannot see the live stream for some
reason which is absolutely annoying
right now like this is the worst time
for this to happen it's like it's like I
haven't been doing this for a while and
then here I am and then
all the worst things could happen at the
same freaking time
but whatever this is what it is to to do
it live
to be here live with we're from with
Griffin This Is How We Do It guys so
let me just see what's going on in my my
world right now let's see
um
let's see Rachel's doing well you know
we are like we are like we're like five
months in which is like so awesome
um you know I I can't believe like and I
you know in like three and a half months
my life is Gonna Change forever right so
that's like something that's like
I don't even know how to describe that
for you people that are already parents
like when did it really hit you you know
like you know it's like you're going
along you see the belly and you're like
okay oh here's something that happened
too I felt the baby like kick for the
first time and I literally burst into
tears you know like it just it just was
like I I don't know I yeah I was like
overwhelmed with emotions
I don't know if anybody else has
experienced that if you have let me know
if that if that's how you experienced it
because for me it was just like
you know what I mean I was like oh my
God I can't believe that that you know
what I'm saying like it was just like I
was like oh I think it's like even
though I've
look we're here I've been doing it but
it's like it will it like hit me in a
way for the first time that I was like
oh wow this is like really happening
even though we've been to doctor's
appointments and everything I don't know
maybe you dad's out there or moms out
there
I guess the mom is already already
feeling it because it's like her body is
changing and all this stuff but it's
like when you're like out like literally
outside of it
and you see the changes and you're just
like how does it affect how does it
affect you and people get affected by
different things at different times but
for me I just was like you know just
seeing that was just like man man oh man
you know what I mean so
I don't know
it was just I don't know
you know maybe you guys
I mean you guys out there can totally
get it right
but for me it just was like wow
anyways
um I don't know this I see a idiot in
chat so sorry I'll get rid of that
because I don't have any mods in here
right now
but okay
um let's get to
let's get to some comments you know
let's get to some comments guys you know
how we do that here on the channel get
some comments
let's see here uh hmb8404
what a great comment how can you not
like this guy right
that's what I'm saying
I appreciate that thank you very much
um let's see back back Stacy underscore
I think that's ibe
onward and upward brother I'm here in El
Paso Texas San Diego New York you're
forever fan
love that let me respond to that rock on
um let's see
uh
uh look somebody said
this is like there's so many like Nick
like so many things people call me
because I have such a cartoon face you
know but this is this is like I don't
know what I you know it's funny like I
guess as a comic like I'm sensitive
right I'm sensitive but I try not to be
too sensitive about everything because
I don't know I think it's about intent
for me like if it's the intent is to be
hurtful I I some sometimes I can I
translate that as like oh this person's
it doesn't matter what they say it's the
intent of why they're saying it
sometimes it's what makes things hurtful
right but in this case it's like you
know
uh Mr K Dash YT says that's his wife
she's cute Groucho Mark's doing right
I mean like
isn't it crazy how just how casual
people
people sold a comedian they just
casually
bro and then they think oh he's gonna
love that right you know it's like
sometimes you know what I mean sometimes
um
let's see
uh whatever somebody's commented on an
old Steve Lee and episode No No Country
for Old Men is a [__] Masterpiece no
question yeah you know
um you know a lot of congratulations a
lot of stuff like that a lot of you know
great comments so anyways that's enough
content that wasn't a lot of great
comments this week but I appreciate you
guys for your comments appreciate you
for being here and all that great stuff
all right so let's see
let me just talk about today I'm just
going to talk about stuff that's been
going on so again I'm doing this movie
that's why I couldn't come last week and
it's just been like a hectic schedule
because it's an independent film and
then we were pushed back because of the
strike then we got the waiver to do the
movie and then so the schedule is real
tight you know it's like it's uh I enjoy
acting it's a great movie I really enjoy
it but it has cost me a lot of money
tell you right now the things I the
things I missed to do it has just been
like you know this is a passion project
I love the director and the cast and
crew and everybody's great so it's like
I enjoy doing uh the movie and I can't I
hope hopefully it'll come out wherever
it's going to come out because who knows
in this day and age things can come out
and all you know you you'll be surprised
where something comes out you'd be like
oh wow it's there hopefully we get into
some festivals and stuff like that so
I've just been busy doing that but one
of the big things I did was I went to
Washington DC and I freaking
directed my buddy Matt rife's special
and it was what an experience it was
guys it was man
um it was just
you know it was so big I think you know
it was Constitution Hall there's
thousands of people there there was all
these cameras and then the crew you know
it's like I've never done it on this
scale before so you know I'm I'm you
know shout out to everybody all the crew
the production company everybody was
very gracious everybody you know with my
green and experience in the technical
parts of the stuff you know because I
had to have this camera meeting you know
that's what you do it's a director you
sit in front of like all the camera
because all the camera operators so we
got seven camera operators you know and
I'm coming in and I'm like hey everybody
you know and they're just looking at me
and they're asking questions like okay
this you know and I'm like whoa you know
the dp's great Director of Photography
you know so he you know if I have any
issues I would talk to him and he would
talk to the people but I got to know
everybody and you know so I'm having
this like big time direct you know I
have that picture on my Instagram you
know it was just like so that was great
and then it just was great it was four
shows you know we CA I've been hanging
I've been going on the road with Matt
because I knew I was gonna I was a part
of this and so I was like you know
helping with this set just like
encouraging him to do like different
things and you know what I mean like I
don't write material because I don't I
just encourage like hey there's more
meat here or
um performed this way that kind of stuff
it's sort of like a directing I was
already doing that stuff with him just a
slight newest set from backwards to
forward so there's moments you want to
capture there's like you know they had
this like jib you know which is just
flying camera coming in capturing shots
and he's such a handsome dude so like
every angle of him looks great you know
what I mean so it just looks like I
can't wait for you guys to see it so
look out for that so that was really
exciting to do that
and it's just another field I want to
get into I realize you know
I used to coach basketball I used to
play basketball so when I was in high
school I played basketball I loved it I
loved playing basketball I loved the
thrill of competition like being on the
court you know I remember I used to grab
rebounds and I would if it was if I was
in a crowd of people and I grabbed a
rebound I would yell like a primal
scream you know I used to do that all
the time I I I I don't know I was a met
I was a trash talker
I used to talk trash
and I loved it so that sort of like
feeling you get
when you're playing basketball and that
feeling of competition I really enjoyed
that but I also found that when I
started coaching basketball
I've had the same thrill
you know when it's like I know that we
practiced a certain play or we practiced
our offense and then when I see them run
it I got the exact same feeling so
that's when I knew I was like oh I love
doing this well I'm starting to feel
that same thing I love doing stand-up
comedy there's nothing better in the
world I love acting it's great I love
bringing people's words to life there's
something special about that this sort
of like relationship you have with the
with the work
um
but there's nothing like stand-up comedy
right just standing on stage and like
making people agree with you or making
people feel things there's just
something about that I love stand-up
comedy
but I gotta tell you directing I'm
getting a similar thrill
the similar thrill of just like
you know helping
keep this thing moving and keep it
together you know I want to see where it
goes I mean I would love to like I've
done like little directing things like I
would like a buddy of mine like put
together a crew to to direct like this
sort of like a little little short not a
short film but it was like a little
short you know comedy shorts and then I
directed that and I was like oh this is
great I loved being on the setting and
encouraging actors to do you know get
get the best out of them and I love it I
love that feeling too so hopefully this
is a new career that I can go into at
this late stage in my life and uh you
know
if if I end up doing that I'd be
thrilled with that you know directing
movies and television shows and like
just having to unders because I have an
understanding of like comedy that I
think I can use that to translate that
skill can translate it into like helping
people bring that out of them if that
makes sense so I really enjoyed that it
was a hell of a hell of a time and I
wanna you know and and it was like a DGA
a Director's Guild
um project so you know
the director's Grill's calling me up
like hey you know you got to join you
know but there's a certain number of
minutes you have to have so I believe
like you have to have like 120 Minutes
of like the finished product and then
once you get to 120 Minutes you you have
to join the Director's Guild so right
now because of the special I have like
75 so keep your fingers crossed guys
that I get more
stuff
um you know what I mean so
yeah
that was like really exciting uh thing
to do you know
all right so let's see what else did I
want to oh so again you know since the
talk since I was talking about unions
something else that is uh going on is
you know so the SAG strike not the sex
track is still going on and they're
actually in talks right now
which is pretty amazing but the wga
they're back the writer's Guild is back
and they have a bunch of terms
um you know and I think they did a
pretty good job
with uh what they came up with you know
so you know so I have the summary of the
stuff right here you know it's like the
summary of the 2023 WG
um
agreement you know so it looks like
increased health and pension
contribution so that's pretty good you
know for people's future
uh the whole the one of the big talks
was about artificial intelligence so now
it's like a I can't write or rewrite
literary material so it's all about the
studio using AI you know but I feel but
they also what's interesting about this
is like
not only can the studio not use it but
the writers can't use it either
or it has to be known you know it's
really it's a strange it's like a
strange thing that's going to be like a
writer can choose to use AI when
performing writing services if the
company consents and provided that the
writer follows applicable company
policies but the company can't require
the writer to use AI software so like
the whole thing was like they didn't
want it to be where like the the let's
say you know the the producer the
producers in the in the um studio is
saying like Okay so yeah two of you guys
we're gonna only like I know normally we
staff this with 10 Riders but I think
two of you guys can do this and we want
you to use the AI to help you they can't
do that now they can't say you have to
do that you know but the writers
themselves can use the AI as a tool
right but that's It's Tricky
so it's like you know I think that's
fair I I think it's fair because I've
been seeing how you can use Ai and I was
like wow this is pretty crazy how how
the AI generate stuff so but I feel like
there's I feel like a lot of writers are
going to be using the AI with no and
they just gonna have to use it and then
they're going to be like well let me
make this my own now but it's a tool
that I don't think is ever going to go
away but it's very interesting how they
put this in the you know the terms uh of
what's going on here uh improve terms
for screenwriting employment this was
one of the big ones so necessary
you know to make sure that you know you
they get they can make a living you know
now this is the one that's now so the
residuals are the one when a feature
length project is made for streaming
with a budget now this is now here's let
me get off this screen for a second so
you can see me full screen here because
I want to talk about this
so one of the big things is about like
residual payments right so they they
trying to figure out well the stream
mirrors the streamers are making all
this money they're either they have our
products on here in perpetuity it's like
we need to start making some money so
you know there was like a an agreement
hit but like as you read this
terminology like I I see the words
benchmarks so when certain benchmarks
are hit and that's what this one is
right here
it goes like this is very tricky wording
in my opinion when a featured length
project is made for streaming
with a budget of 30 million dollars or
more the minimum initial compensation
for a story or teleplay is a hundred
thousand dollars an 18 increase from the
current rate okay so you're gonna get
more money to make the feature and a 26
increase in residual base okay so
there's gonna be a little bit more
residuals combined with a foreign
residual improvements described below
yeah because what was happening is like
the foreign market so you know Netflix
for instance has like 200 something
subscribers and a lot of those people
have that I think it's probably foreign
but and then you know you would make a
movie and they're playing it in Istanbul
and you didn't you the the production
wasn't getting any money for that you
know so it was kind of like hey what's
going on here with that so I think
they're trying to
um
they tried to get some compensation for
that
uh
uh so the thing though is that
combined with the foreign residual
improvements describe below this results
in a three-year residual of 216
000 for projects on the largest service
49 increase under the 2020 NBA so it's
like
they very much are saying like again and
that's very particular wording
if the budget is 30 million dollars or
more
I mean most of these little movies that
are gonna come on
Netflix
dang gonna be 30 million dollar budget
movies
so it's like this is going to be a
situation of The Haves and the have-nots
there's gonna be a lot of projects that
are going to be made and they're not
going to fall into this category and
they're going to fall short of these
benchmarks on purpose kind of like when
like a professional athlete has
incentives in their contract where it's
like if they start 17 games they'll get
an extra million dollars right then game
17 is coming and then the coach all of a
sudden benches this person you know and
they're like wait why am I being bitched
you know it's like well because secretly
upstairs was like yeah we don't want to
pay him so bench him or whatever you
know what I mean like there's they find
ways around this and I think this is
going to be one of the things I think
it's going to be like you're going to go
to Netflix or these companies and be
like hey we want to make this movie and
this is the budget we need and it's
going to be around 30 million and
they're going to be like um we'll make
25 million is the budget you're going to
have no more and you're gonna have to
and then what are you gonna do you're
not gonna make your movie of course
you're gonna wanna make your movie I
think they're gonna find a way to like
get around this thing this deal I don't
think this is gonna necessarily be a
good deal for the for the less you know
this is going to be a great deal for the
top five percent movie stars big shows
you know stranger things this is gonna
be great for uh Wednesday this is gonna
be great for but like what about like
this little movie I'm in this is a very
small budget movie right I'm sure this
I'm sure this you know there's a lot of
movies being made for like less than two
million dollars
and so those movies are gonna they're
gonna be like okay yeah we'll put your
little movie on our platform but
residuals you know like it's just I
don't know if this is necessarily a
great deal but I don't know I don't know
all the particulars you know I I just
read through this and I was like huh
this is interesting you know
um but I do think they should so they go
so here's the thing I'm talking about
right here viewership based streaming
bonuses
The Guild negotiated a new residual
based on viewership okay uh
uh if a series and films that are viewed
by 20 or more of the services domestic
subscribers in the first 90 days of
released release or in the first 90 days
in any subsequent uh a year get a bonus
equal to 50 of the fixed domestic
foreign residuals okay
um
you know what I mean for instance
projects written under the new MBA on
the largest streaming services would
receive a bonus of nine thousand for
half hour episodes sixteen thousand for
one hour episodes or forty thousand for
a streaming feature over 30 million
dollars in budget you see what I'm
saying
so like
so
twenty percent of the subscriber base is
over 20 million people a
so like you come out with a show
and if if 20 million people don't watch
it
that's it for you you're not you're not
gonna fall under this
I think that they agree to these numbers
because they know the numbers I think
the streaming services know
that they make a lot of garbage or I
shouldn't say that they make a lot of
stuff that that it just goes by the
wayside not a lot of people
are watching it so therefore they know
oh yeah yeah yeah we'll do this if you
get 20 20 then we'll we'll let you look
at stuff we'll let you see the numbers
20 well you know you're gonna get more
residuals 20 you can and then it's gonna
be like we're gonna go and watch in
three years No One's Gonna Get this it's
gonna be like five shows and like four
movies it'll be like the big budget
movies and that's it so I don't know
I don't know man but they did increase
the terms of employment which I like you
know it's like it's more money I think
it's like
um you know writer producer weekly
minimums like there's minimums they have
to have you know which I think it's fair
like if you're if you're on a show
that's got it goes
you know they're writing 10 episodes of
a show it's like all right you can't
just hire somebody for two weeks and
then fire them well you know it's like
no if they're on the show they're on the
show so we'll see how that goes they
have like they've they increased the
terms of employment and the titles and
and all that so there's more money to be
made so hopefully sag goes in the same
direction you know hopefully sag will do
that so that's going to be pretty
interesting to see uh what's going on
with that man but listen uh today's show
is brought to you by door Dash doordash
and I want to thank doordash for being a
sponsor of the show
I love that you can get groceries from
doordash get the grocery shopping done
maybe you maybe you made some pancakes
and you don't have any syrup and you're
like oh no what are we gonna do you just
hit up door Dash BOOM guess what here
they come with the syrup you know it's
just a convenience of getting what you
want right to your door that's what
doordash provides it's always a trusted
delivery person the process is pretty
simple you can get it delivered at your
door or they can leave it you you know
there's all kinds of different options
for how you interact with the driver
and I love it I love doordash especially
like when you're trying to cook because
I cook a lot now and sometimes you do
miss some things sometimes you just need
some onions and a couple of other things
you just boom hit up doordash person
goes so you know then now you you're
helping somebody they're employed you're
getting what you want the whole thing
works out great because of doordash is
doing what they do
you've you've trusted doordash to
deliver your restaurant favorites now
you can get doordash to deliver your
groceries
I love it get 50 off your first doordash
order up to 20 value when you use code r
w g grocery one word rwg which stands
for riffing with Griffin grocery at
checkout limited time offer terms apply
that's 50 off up to twenty dollars on
your first order through doordash when
you enter rwg grocery listen if you've
never used it before use it you got to
use it at least once get you get this
use your rwg grocery code and get up to
twenty dollars off your first order I
think it's worth trying it at least one
time but thank you doordash for being a
sponsor of the show
all right
thanks for being here once again
everyone
um
so
let me tell you what's going on I have
like a a personal situation going on
here so as you know
I've been talking about getting this
Fisker ocean
okay Fisker shout out to Fisker I think
Fisker is a great company I think they
will be a great company I think what
they're trying to do
with the sustainable materials making an
electric car you know make it leather
made from recyclable materials like all
the things they're trying to do the the
message they're trying to send is like
you know to have the smallest car carbon
footprint
they're trying their best it's hard to
do especially you're selling a luxury
item you just you're just trying to be
that person in the market Okay so
I gotta know so let me just go back so
five years ago 2019 yeah right 2019 20
21 22 23 yeah we're like it's like four
years ago really
actually even before that because you
know how you get like the next year
model early anyway I wanted an electric
car I just did I was sick of paying for
gas
in my car like at the time gas prices
were like similar to what they are now
and I was like putting I was like what
the amount because I drive all over the
place I'm spending all this money on
gaps and I was like you know what I want
to get an electric car so I'm looking
around and it's new at the time
everybody had a Tesla I didn't want to
get a Tesla because I was like ah
everybody's got a Tesla like that I
don't want that right I want to be a
little different so Jaguar they had a
new car this you know new
i-pace
I went I saw it I loved it I got it you
know it's expensive car you know what I
mean
um and I bought it which I regret I
shouldn't have bought it that's the
that's the thing I'm bringing up right
now I bought it but I did it because you
could borrow like it's like a a thing
you could do you know like if you have a
bunch of money in the bank
you know so instead of getting a loan
from the bank get a loan against
yourself so you could like you know you
could do this like if you have enough
money in the bank you could
borrow against your own money and the
interest rate will be way lower it'll be
it'll be way lower so you know I paid
you know and then you don't even feel it
you don't it doesn't feel as as as as
much so you buy the car outright you
know I'm paying back myself because it's
my money right and then the service fee
to the bank it's just a lower interest
rate anyways I don't know how the
technical thing works like that but it
does
you get one of these like loans from
your bank okay
so anyways
um then so I I have this uh um
jaguar and I get it and I like it at
first it's nice it's Jaguar makes a
great car it's quick my car is fast it
fast but then you start having the
issues of charging where you charge when
you can charge because at the time I
didn't have a charger at my place yet so
I had to go to different places and it
was it was kind of a hassle because
you're like it's like having a dog you
know you have to like go water to you
know I gotta go feed the dog and walk
the dog that's how it was with your car
and then you're spending like 30 40
minutes at a place like you're just
sitting in your car while you're
charging so it became a thing where I
was like I had to get a charger at my
place and then it became a thing about
miles you know living in La man you know
you had to go
if you're just in a city electric car is
great because you can zip around get
back but it became a thing where like
the
270 miles you get on a EV on my EV it
wasn't I find it wasn't really enough
especially if you want to go like my
parents live in Oxnard you know I'm I'm
going to San Diego a lot it's like oh
this became a thing you know well this
isn't enough but that's because the
technology was new and it's getting
better and better and better now let me
say this at the time Lucid Motors
had just started and I'm I went to go
look at that car and I was like oh this
car is dope I wanted it but the company
was new and it was expensive and I was
like but I and I and it I didn't know
when it was going to be ready and then
you know you don't know if companies are
gonna make it you heard all these issues
about Tesla before they really got their
[__] together right so it was like oh do
I want to be a part of The Growing Pains
of this company right Jaguar is an
established company it's established
they've been around for Generations
right so you go all right I get the Jag
my my review of ipace is the car is
great the technology is not you know at
the time the the UI was slow it didn't
have enough techy stuff and I like that
stuff you know actually the new version
of the ipace to Tech is great now it
because I I because they upgraded all of
their cars the Land Rovers Jaguars they
all have this new UI that I really like
because and I I know that because when
my car needed to get serviced they would
give me a Jag they would give me like a
different car and it had that new stuff
and I was like oh I love this and then I
had this thing where like the 2019
version had 3G technology in it and then
all the companies without warning just
turned 3G off so that became a thing you
know because that's how you get all the
information on your car but they
upgraded my antenna so not then they had
4G but anyways I knew that when the time
was to turn this car in I knew that the
next time I got an electric car I was
gonna lease it
cut to Fisker they're coming out with
this beautiful SUV Fisker ocean
everything on the website
on their website they talk about the
lease program Fisker fleece lease or
whatever they was called I was under an
impression that I could lease this car I
ordered it a year ago I had to put five
actually 52.50 down on the car okay and
now I'm ready I'm all through the year
I'm waiting for this car I'm asking what
the hell is going on where's the car
what's the car they finally start making
deliveries I'm like okay where's my car
then I have to go on Instagram and be
like hey man where's my car and then
they were finally like oh Eric and they
call me they're like hey don't worry
your car's on the way and it's gonna
come and I'm like yeah yeah now the time
comes I'm at the finish line
and they tell me I have to buy the car
and the 52 5250 is non-refundable
I'm just it's a I I was torn man it
sucks
because I don't want to buy this car
first of all everything they said that
they were gonna deliver about the car
hasn't happened yet it's all like well
in the future it's gonna do this
it's all kinds of like communication
issues because I'm in these forums and I
see what people are dealing with
with like you know maintenance and
customer service and they don't have
their infrastructure in place yet it's
not you know they got a few service
centers not even service centers just
like plate like little storefronts where
you can go see the car and stuff like
that but in terms of like how they deal
with you they ain't there yet
so I did and I know in three years this
car is going to be like come on like
they're already talking about
partnering with Tesla and changing the
the the uh the outlet
so they could get the Tesla Outlet so
you can go to the superchargers without
getting an adapter that's coming
so that's gonna be in three years right
in three years that's when I want this
car
and I don't want to buy it I want to
lease because I know that EV technology
is going to keep improving the battery
size is going to keep getting bigger and
when and anytime it's new they don't
know yet that's why like you don't see
any Hummer EVS on the on the streets
remember how like LeBron James was like
you know they they were they were
hinting at the Hummer for two years now
they I you can't find one of those cars
on the streets because you read all the
reviews about them they're too heavy
they can't drive well it's like it's too
expensive to charge them it's like like
all these issues so it's like you don't
want to be on the ground floor of that
you know so that's what I don't I don't
want to do this I didn't want to get to
Fisker I was like you it really ticks me
off because I'm like you made it seem
like I can lease this car and then at
the Finish Line you tell me I gotta buy
it and the person I was talking to on
the phone who I was dealing with I could
tell that person was like oh yeah I know
I understand how you must feel you know
so then I had to make this Sophie's
Choice
do I lose the 5 000 did I deposit it
like over a year ago so it's not even
like I feel that money right and this is
first world problems I obviously totally
there's people that are listening that
this is like what are you talking about
Griffin I get it right but I'm just
telling you my truth okay I'm just
talking about my truth right now all
right so this is what it is so yeah I
don't feel the five thousand it's like
whatever you know what I mean I know the
trolls think I'm broke because
I'm just gonna send Rachel to work
harder at Target
anyway it's like it doesn't matter right
so I'm just like uh it's the principle
of it
so I had this choice
do I
buy the car and deal with the the
uncertainty or do I get my peace of mind
and Lease cut to Lucid Motors is
offering a lease program that lets me
know the companies where they need to be
because they're they're going yeah we
could at least you can at least now and
we'll take the car back and we know we
can sell it or do whatever but they're
offering a lease program and I was like
I went I went down I went to Century
City they have a lucid Motors there I
looked at the car and I remembered how I
loved this car when I sat in it four
years ago
and then I just impulse by Major Choice
Rachel was with me I looked at her and
said I love this car I want to get this
and so I did it
I ordered my Lucid Motors car so I'm
getting a a grant not no not the grant
the Grand Touring is like too expensive
that's like buying a Ferrari or
something but I'm getting the air
touring model I love it the glass roof
and the tech the tech and I've been
looking at a lot of videos I think
there's still some issues and they keep
improving them I love the car that can
get like an over-the-air update that's
what I love about the EV cars too
you know it's like oh man this is wrong
and then they send you an update you're
like your phone right it's great so I
got I'm getting that car that's what I'm
getting guys and then what I'm gonna do
is when I get the car I'm gonna do a
complete review of the car the whole
process of going to get it I'm gonna
bring my my GoPro and that's going to be
that episode so if you're listening to
the podcast this is great and I'll still
have my listening portion you know like
the stuff that I do right now but you
might want to take a gander at that on
YouTube uh oh
here we go National this is a national
alert wow live on stream
laughs
uh you know what I mean uh this is so we
just had a national alert Guy this is a
test of the national wireless emergency
alert system
okay well that worked huh that's crazy
so
uh
uh you know what I mean um so I see
somebody in chat said I paint cars I've
yet to see a Fisker or Lucid well I
would hope that
I think that when you're buying a luxury
car I don't think that
um first of all you wouldn't see Fisker
unless somebody's trying to do a custom
paint job and I don't think someone's
gonna do that because the of the
warranties of the car like actually a
lot of stuff is covered like oh that's
another thing too man
or two things let me go back so I have
this Jaguar right i-pace you they don't
hold their value electric cars don't
hold their value so that's the awesome
thing when you go into the luxury if you
want to get a luxury EV
that this sucker man I'm having issues
like I'm gonna go sell my car today you
you that's the thing too that and I know
that this Fisker ocean is not gonna hold
this value this new version of this new
base like the newest version now like
this just you know in three years No
One's Gonna want this one because they
would have made tons of improvements and
you could be like well why would I pay
whatever amount of money for that car
when they already making this new
version that's like better you know I
mean so that's the thing too about so
anybody out there trying to get on a
lecture car like you know if you want
the electric car because you want like
not to pay for gas and you want
something economical there's plenty of
options out there that are under forty
thousand dollars that you could get
Hyundai makes some good ones Toyota all
these companies are making really great
cars that you could get great prices you
know but you know Daddy's doing okay so
I wanted to get you know so that's not
to deal with but I don't imagine you
would see if you paint cars any of these
cars because they got very expensive
paint jobs on the cars already is the
point I was trying to make there so
um yeah man so I don't know guys I'll
keep you informed of like the journey
I'm going on but we'll see how it goes
but as of right now I got my Lucid uh I
got it like ordered and I'm I'm ready to
pick it up but you know they they
actually sent an Uber black for you and
then you go to the center and they you
know you get your car all set up and all
that kind of stuff so I'm looking for
looking forward to doing all that
um we'll you know we'll see how that
goes
um
you know so yeah that was like the the
the the
line producer of the show of the movie
I'm doing just hit me up here can you go
get a haircut
[Laughter]
guys
that's uh
my little
um thing that's going on
with me so all right let's go to the
crazy internet topics
crazy internet topics of the week
and once again thanks for being here
with original Griffin so this is one
that I had this whole like internet
situation with so the new California law
raises minimum wage for fast food
workers to 20 an hour okay
twenty dollars an hour they're going to
raise the minimum wage how do I feel
about this whatever fast food companies
make a lot of money yeah pay your
workers right I think we learned during
the pandemic that people that that's not
a great job not that we already didn't
know that that wasn't a great job but at
the same time it's like
people were like Ugh they were getting
money from the government and then it
was like why do I want to go back to
this to me it was always a sign that
like
you didn't make a good work environment
either some of these places that's why
people were just walking out of their
jobs they were like see a Burger King
and just leave in the job because
they're like why am I putting up with
all this nonsense I'm putting up I have
to deal with shitty customers my manager
is an ass and then I make no money so I
get it so then you get to do something
and then you know people I don't know
what the purpose of this is but but as
California is set to implement a new law
that will raise the minimum wage for
faster workers or twenty dollars per
hour starting on April 1st of next year
making it the highest guaranteed base
salary in the industry the move
recognizes that many fast food workers
are the primary earners in low-income
households okay trying to do their part
here's my feeling about it
there's no way that these fast food
companies are going to just roll over
and be like okay we're gonna pay out
more money there's no way they're just
gonna roll over and do that and the way
they're gonna get back is raising the
prices so like I wrote on this on this
thing and it's on my one of my favorite
sites to look at on Instagram puberty
p-u-b-i-t-y follow them they got a lot
of great stories I wrote well here comes
the 75 kids meal with no toy
right now what do you think I mean by
that uh that's what I mean by I mean
that corporate greed is going to take
over I mean that like did these
companies are gonna be like oh okay you
want us to pay our workers twenty
dollars an hour all right well we're
gonna raise the prices and we're gonna
not have as many workers
they're going to start doing the
self-service is going to be everywhere
now they're gonna they're gonna look
into robot technology where you just you
order you order and then there's like an
arm comes
you know what I mean and then there's
your hamburger that's what they're gonna
start doing they're gonna be like okay
yeah we'll raise the prices but we're
just gonna look you know we're not gonna
have any we're going to raise the prices
and we're not going to hire as many
people that's how they're going to do it
you know but of course the internet
being what it is these people like you
want to talk about some dumb comments
from people there's this one idiot who
was like going at me like this is this
is what I'm saying like this and I'm
gonna tell you what I think about this
because I know why this happened so this
guy writes literally every country that
pays their fast food staff a living wage
has practically the same prices as us
you would think you'd understand the
sentiment of getting your fair share of
the profits considering your line of
work hey dumb [__]
I'm on your side
I'm just you it's like here's what
happens
I realize it's from this interaction I
realized
people
interpret
what you're saying
to what they want it to be
so they can make their point
that's what the internet is lacking is
back and forth dialogue discourse
instead of assuming what somebody thinks
you should ask but you don't get to do
that on the internet and then when
you're a comic even if because like I'm
being facetious this is even a joke too
it's a joke and I'm being serious when I
say well here comes the 75 meal kids
meal with no toy
like
this idiot took that as I'm anti-worker
what you know what I mean so instead of
like being like hey Griffin uh you know
what are you saying then I could be like
yeah these companies are greedy they're
not gonna roll over and do this no this
guy had to Virtue signal get on his
internet high horse you know you know
what I mean all the uh all the freaking
like keyboard Warriors have to show hey
everybody that's looking at this I'm a
good person and I need to show you by
attacking this basic cable celebrity
anyways it's really stupid but getting
back to the real point of this is like I
think Gavin Newsom is a [__] idiot
you know I really do I think this guy is
he's the he is an internet governor
you know what I mean he's like total
internet governor and he's like oh yeah
oh look what I'm doing without it's like
it it needs to be more than just hey
we're gonna raise the prices and hey you
guys can do whatever you want like what
it's like I just don't understand how
that's going to benefit anybody because
I I'm telling you we're going to be
paying for and maybe that's not a bad
thing you know it's like you know
fast food's already expensive in my
opinion have y'all been to some of these
places recently
you know I just remember because I'm 51
so I can remember when you could go to
you went to fast food because it was
cheap man sometimes you go you get a few
things maybe you're getting you know
that's three four or five of you and you
just hey let's get some burgers and
fries and so we can go to this whatever
and you like damn sixty dollars I mean
it's I'm just telling you it's like they
already been raising prices and they're
gonna raise them even more after this so
yeah that's what I feel about that
foreign
next one
did y'all see Britney Spears
I'm like Brittany what are you doing
at this point she's just trolling us
right
I mean Britney's trolling us right
you know like this spot in her house
where she does all her dancing
it's like
do you right like what is it what should
it matter like let Britney do you do you
girl but when you were in a
conservatorship for 13 years because
they thought you were crazy
they thought you were unstable they
thought you needed supervision
and then we fought everybody was like
you know being on their high horse like
we gotta save Brittany and then you
dancing with butcher knives
I mean
we starting to go uh oh
oh
conservative [__]
I don't you know I don't know
again
if she's just trolling and she's fully
aware of like that she's just like
getting attention because she needs it
because she's not really Britney Spears
anymore you know what I mean it just
happens to everyone you know Britney's
going through like Brittany and Madonna
going through the same thing where they
just can't like they it's like when
you're that the highest of highs and you
were just celebrated for being like an
artist and then you're also like
sexualized and you know all of the
things that that go on with being a
superstar in the public eye it don't
last forever and then you're just like a
you know this chick you know what I mean
and then you're like who's this like
this don't even look like oops I Did It
Again person who is this
who is this what are you doing
so I don't know
I don't know maybe I'm just venting and
commenting on this subject because this
is just craziness all right the next one
guys so you know the new iPhone's out
right okay new iPhones out and they
finally getting rid of the lightning
thing so they go into a more Universal
thing which I'm like great let's go
Universal with that because I used to
hate remember like it's like 10 15 years
ago they kept changing the chord no
warning hotels still have those radios
with the stupid plug
from like iPhone 2. you know what I mean
you ever go to a hotel and you're like
who's using that you can't even plug
this in so now all everything's going to
this more Universal
USBC like your laptop is USBC now my
iPad is USBC now they're just gonna get
rid of lightning let's go USBC but I
have a problem with this
Apple warrants people
not to use Android USBC charges to avoid
overheating nah man
that's on purpose
y'all these companies stop
stop with this I almost feel like
Android's doing that on purpose yeah
let's put like an extra wattage in ours
so when iPhone people use it it blows
them up and then so you have to use the
Android or something make it Universal
across the board stop this nonsense man
make it Universal so we can use whatever
chords we want and not have an issue
it was just craziness man absolute
craziness
all right next one
dude what's up with Joe Biden's dog
Joe Biden's family dog bites yet another
secret service agent making it his 11th
attack
this dog has bit 11 people
sometimes
you know
sometimes it's time to go
[Music]
um
that dog gotta go
imagine you're a secret service agent
and it's like your job it's one thing
when you a mailman
and you
have to deliver mail and you have to
walk through a yard to get the mail to
the mailbox and there's some big ass
German Shepherd trying to bite you so
you're like well God damn man do
something about your dog right so you
have to put up with that because you're
a male person to deal with all that
right okay
then
but if you're a secret service agent
imagine your job is to protect this
man's life
your job is to make sure he gets from
point A to point B safely
and his dog is biting you
imagine
you know you and JFK's
convertible
you know what I mean you're already mad
as a convertible that's the president of
the United States what the hell are we
doing in a convertible during a parade
you know and
you know it turns the corner
you know you and you may you go oh wait
a minute I see a glint and then the dog
bites you and then pal president dead I
mean that's how that kind of stuff
happens
you know what I mean like that's
probably maybe we didn't know about that
JFK had a dog that was biting people and
this is how it happened
this is like I would be out if I'm if
I'm a secret service agent and the
president's dog is attacking my fellow
agents I'm like
your dumb ass dog out of here dude
anyways
crazy story to me
oh is that the last one yo that was the
last one you know what we had a good
episode today
you know I'm back I'm uh off the heels
of working hard and you know I had a
really late call time today so I was
glad I can get it and I haven't even
been on the golden hour either so check
me out on the golden hour but you know
what guys this week guess what I'm gonna
be a laugh Boston Friday and Saturday if
you're in the Boston area and you want
to see me do some comedy come on out to
laugh Boston in Boston
so check me out there I haven't even
been able to update my website so go to
laugh Boston's website I'm gonna try to
do that today get those ticket that
ticket link up there you go to my
Instagram I put it in my story uh so you
can go to laugh Boston's uh Instagram
and get get some tickets man so anyways
I'll see you guys in Boston and I
appreciate everybody for uh you know
always being loyal to the show uh you
know great stuff I I don't even know
what to say sometimes you guys are
really really fantastic
um
I don't know
I mean you know what I mean like it's
just I love doing riffing with Griffin
it's it's been it's like one of my it's
almost like a guilty pleasure for me you
know and I just I still I still do want
to grow this show so you know I I need
you know spread the word for me let
people know hey I really enjoy this
podcast it's one of my favorite podcasts
to watch so that definitely will help
the show grow all right but you know
what time it is now
how we do at this point in the show
oh yeah
it's that rap recap
[Music]
yeah Daddy's back
uh matter of fact
all week
by the door
oh
that beat should be a little longer
anyways thanks for watching river
Griffin and I'll see you guys next week